a
okay I think everyone has the handouts
so Chris take it away good morning for
the record Chris Shay from the LBA um
before you you received three documents
the one that I handed to you was the
department of administrative Services
Revenue Focus document um commissioner
step provided the Dr presentation and
then Jennifer 4 provided a um blog
document that Phil slon has prepared
related to the
revenu so my purpose real quick here was
just to bring the committee's focus on
onto the revenue Focus um remind you
that there is a document that is out
there that you should have access to on
a regular basis um if you were to look
at the first page you can see for the
current month which would have been the
April Revenue um you exceeded your plan
by 38
million dollars you know on the right
hand side of the column gives you little
Snippets as to why you may have exceeded
or not exceeded a revenue plan for a
particular tax revenue or Revenue
and then if you flip to the third page
there's a big table it says general
education funds that gives you the
year-to date on your Revenue Collections
and it splits it by the general fund and
education trust fund and you can go
through that and see what revenues are
up and what revenues are down and in
which buckets they are up and down if
you go to the bottom row where it says
total
receipts you're going to see for the
general fund that you're
$68.84 for the education trust fund
you're $26.4 million below
plan and then when you combine the two
your general education trust fund
revenues are only 142 .4 million ahead
of
plan so I just wanted to start with that
with you give the document to you when
Lindsay's done with the presentation
from Dr I'll come back up and talk a
little bit more about some of the
individual ndra taxes as well as give
you kind of a snapshot of what our
office is anticipating for um the banum
in terms of some of the expenditures and
um unanticipated Appropriations that
have have come forward um just so you
can hear about that because you sure
you're going to hear it from your peers
you know as you have bills with
Appropriations that you want to
pass so that's all I have for right
now thank you any questions before we
hear from yes represent fellows thank
you I have a question about um the
business profits and The Business
Enterprise tax and I'll let Dr answer
any of those questions it'll probably be
part of the presentation that they're
going to thank
you okay thank
you w welcome thank you good morning Mr
chair members of the committee for the
record Lindsay stpp I'm the commissioner
at the Department of Revenue and with me
is Lauren ulvan she's our senior
financial analyst we're going to kind of
tag team this
presentation it should look somewhat
similar um if you remember what our
presentation looked like during the
revenue estimating process um but we'll
go through Slide by slide tax by tax if
it's okay with the chair we'll pause at
the end of each tax for any questions
and then move through the taxes that way
sounds good thank
you so what you have on page one
is the various scenarios that we run
when we're trying to determine where we
believe the current fiscal year revenues
will end up as you may remember our
Revenue estimating process typically um
takes current year Revenue we estimate
where it will end the current fiscal
year and then we Pro um estimate a
growth rate going into the next year so
this is what we determine or this is
what we call our base year so in this
case it's fiscal year 24
we are 10 months through the year we
have two months to go so we know most of
the revenues at this point so we're
feeling pretty confident in our
estimates but we do still run these
scenarios where we look at what plan
revenue is if we were to apply the
percent compared to plan for the
remaining two months of the year where
would we end up if we were to compare
this fiscal year to the prior fiscal
year and assume that same percentage is
going to continue for the rest of the
year year and then we say okay what if
actual revenues year-to date what if we
meet plan for the remainder of the year
or what if we say actual revenues year
to date and the last two months of the
year are exactly the same as last year
so those are the scenarios that we run
again this point in the year 10 months
through they kind of start coming
together um but we did go through and we
did pick the scenario that we believe to
be um the most accurate for the last two
months and so we'll cover that for each
tax type then for each tax Ty we'll talk
about what we think the growth rate will
be for fiscal year
25 okay so on page two just as a
reminder these are your fiscal year 25
Committee of conference Surplus
statement amounts so these are amounts
that were not included in the revenue
estimates that this committee and the
senate committee worked on these are
adjustments that needed to be made to
those estimates for legislation that was
pending at the time that you were doing
your Revenue estimates so these are
included um as a surplus statement item
and then we will make these adjustments
as part of the revenue estimates for the
most part for fiscal year 25 um the most
significant adjustments are between bet
and BPT uh for the education trust fund
and the general fund we have a small
amount of money that's attributable to
Dr audit positions that need to be added
in and then the appeal uh the repeal
excuse me of the interest and dividends
tax
all right we're going to Dive Right In
on page three with the heavy hitter
business
taxes so historically business taxes
have been split roughly 76.4% BPT and
23.6% bet so BPT is the largest portion
of the business
taxes some factors to consider when
we're estimating for the remainder of 24
and into 25 fiscal year to date we are
3.3 million or 3% below plan Senator
Rosen Wald and I were just commenting in
the hallway we've nailed it we've done
pretty well with our business tax
estimates and our plan um for those of
us that have been doing this for a
little while this is the closest we've
been to plan I think in quite some time
so we are tracking right on plan with
business taxes as a
whole fiscal year to date we're about
38.3 million or 3.6% below prior year
again that was anticipated
in the plan and the largest reason for
that is the next bullet which is refunds
resulting from the credit carry forward
limitations that went into effect for
tax years 2022 and after so at this
point businesses cannot take as a credit
credit carry forward more than 500% of
their liability they have to have any
excess over 500% refunded to them so
just under 50% 48.8% of the refunds
issued year-to date were related to
these credit carry forward caps so about
half of our refunds year-to date for
business taxes are because of this
credit carry forward
cap taxpayers who kept 500% of their
liability as a credit carry forward were
20.4% of those refunds so what that
means is taxpayers are not just stopping
at that 500% they're going beyond that
that because this cap will lower to
250% in 2 years so we are seeing
taxpayers not just hit the cap and
refund over 500 they're going beyond
that they are doing essentially what we
wanted them to do which was to reduce
the liability that we were carrying on
our books as a state um can I just stop
you for a second sure um are you
informing customers
that I'm guessing they automatically
don't know there's a 500% cap so how are
they being informed and then are they
being also told that next year it'll be
250% so we do have um technical
information releases that go out um
where we update taxpayers on legislation
the CPA Society tax preparers are very
well aware of this change um but when we
talked about the the fiscal impact of
this change we said well we don't know
whether we're going to see it
necessarily in refunds where they get to
the end of the year and they have hit
that cap or if taxpayers are going to
make a proactive active adjustment to
their estimate payments and essentially
use up some of their credit by lowering
their estimates what we've essentially
seen is that taxpayers have waited for
the return and just taken the money um
as a refund as opposed to lowering their
um credits on on account thank you I
will say that um based on our analysis
the majority of the the impact the
refund impact as a result of this cap
has been felt in fiscal 24 we do not
anticipate that this same cap um refunds
due to hitting this 500% cap will be
seen in
25 so there the the the impact is kind
of now and we've seen it and we're not
seeing large um potential refunds
sitting out there that we're waiting for
them to hit we've seen most of them come
through representative
Aly yes representative Aly thank you I
think that most answers my question but
uh the people taxpayers who had 500% or
more um
as uh in in the treasury on are you
saying that most of them
took on most of that this
year yes so they've most of the impact
of the 500% cap has already been felt in
the
so what I'm I'm saying is did they go
down to 250 or 100% or did they they
just go down to
500 well so what you'll see in that
second bullet is
that you had 20.4 of the refunds that
were issued due to the credit carryover
cap only went to 500 so the remaining
79.6 if my math is Right went more than
I can't necessarily say to what extent
they went to because their liability is
going to change in the next year so I
can't necessarily say oh so many went
all the way down to the 250 because
their liability fluctuates year to year
but for the most part they went beyond
the 500% and that could be a variety of
reasons that could be because they're
anticipating the 250 it could be because
they are sensing some slow down in the
economy and they want their cash in hand
as opposed to sitting at Dr it can be
for a variety of
reasons is that
helpful yes I'm not sure that does that
really tells us that they aren't going
to come back the 500 ones and hit us
with another 200 uh
50% they could right they could load up
their estim next year and hit us again
with the 500 cap but what we've seen is
for the most part most taxpayers they've
had to go to that 500 and some have gone
even beyond that and what's pending out
there is not anything that we feel to be
larger than what we anticipated for
going forward in fiscal
25 and just just so members are aware
there there is another wild card in this
and that is the um um the chair of the
Senate ways and means and I discussed
slowing down the um the rate so that
it's not 250 next year it would be 400%
from what I understand the Senate has
passed that um and therefore um and I
think that's that's coming to that
should be coming back uh or not coming
back coming to the house so that if we
if we limit it to 400% that's going to
make a difference in these do you know
what they attached it to I don't know
Senator not to put you on the spot do
you know sorry I don't it's okay thank
thank you representative PL yeah tough
question to answer but what could
motivate a business not to get every re
dollar refund they could get why keep
250 or 500% in in the state's hands sure
good question um I think there's a few
things one if businesses um liability
fluctuates year to year and they're
concerned that their liability could
increase yet next year in order to
potentially um not be faced with a large
tax bill they might keep some money on
account um second interest rates are now
better um in other accounts but for a
while that the interest rate that the
state would pay was not a bad place to
keep your money um third a lot of our
large credit carryovers are from very
large multinational organizations and
New Hampshire is just a small portion of
their portfolio of tax liability that
they're just not paying as close
attention to what they have on account
here um their liability are much much
larger in in other states so I think
those are the three primary reasons
makes sense yeah yes represent ores
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so if I understand to
help alleviate concerns maybe here
around this table is that at
approximately 79% going below the 500
level it's taking the pressure off that
valve of wow we could get hit with this
in the future people are going to dip so
we don't you're not concerned about that
at all at this point correct right so
the in the Years leading up to this
legislation we saw the credit carryover
that businesses were keeping on the
books here in New Hampshire kind of
growing at rates that were somewhat
concerning um there was also a change
recommended by our state Auditors for
how we should account for that liability
historically we had not accounted for
that liability on our books a change in
opinion of the Auditors um the state
decided that that liability now should
be reflected so in order to reduce that
liability and potential hit to the state
we the legislature decided to put this
cap in you know my opinion is that
highly it's it's highly unlikely that we
would have been called upon at one
moment to issue all of those credit
carry forwards that would be a very
extreme circumstance um but it certainly
lessens what the state is liable for and
lessens the liability that we need to
account on our books followup followup
uh thank you
so just that of curiosity what is the
rate of interest the state has been
paying
approximately I'm going to get back to
you on that because I don't want to
missp well yeah the interest rate was
about 1% elsewhere or slightly less or
depending so I figured the state must be
doing three to five maybe or six if but
people were keeping money in there for
that reason yeah agree I will get you um
we issue a a technical information
release every year of the interest that
we pay and the interest rate that we
char charge they are not the same um we
charge more than we pay but it has um
the whole history on it so you'll be
able to see so we'll make sure the
committee gets thank you uh
representative
Southworth thank you um so we had um
discussed quite a bit what would be the
impact of the single sales Factor oh
yeah you're jumping ahead would it help
or would it hurt yeah and um so far it
looks like it's helping there's an
increase do you have any sense if that's
a trend or that kind of predicts the
future or is it too
soon I well you can answer that but I'm
I'm beginning to wonder whether we
should let you finish this first can I
ask about the one we were in okay just
there or just one thing say that the
reason that this was done was that the
representative major had been fighting
for years to get us to do something
about about this which was ballooning
and it was ballooning before
the interest rates went down correct so
that can't be the whole reason for this
no I I mean I think representative pl's
question was somewhat of a hypothetical
and these are things that I think
taxpayers consider I don't think there's
any one thing whether it be interest
rates or that they're not paying
attention to their liability in New
Hampshire or that they're you know going
to potentially face a higher liability
next year I'm just providing examples as
to why taxpayers don't just take all
their money back because I I honestly
had the same thought why would you why
wouldn't you just take what was yours
and only pay exactly what you owe and
these are some of the things that we've
kind of seen happen over the last few
years it was an excellent answer thank
you okay we'll let you uh finish up BPT
and bet and then we'll see question um
so as representative Southworth
mentioned um another change that we have
been following was the impact of the
move to single sales Factor so single
sales factor is an apportionment
methodology and this applies when you
have businesses that operate within
multiple States how did they determine
what portion of their income is a
tributable to each state so we have
moved to single sales factors so a
business is just going to look at their
sales to New Hampshire previously we had
three factors we looked at property
payroll and sales legislature made the
determination that the only factor that
we were going to use going forward at
this point was single sales Factor when
the legislature was making this change
we provided numerous analyses and what
we saw is that the impact of single
sales Factor could fluctuate year toe so
some years it was a positive for the
state some years it was a negative for
the state so what we've
seen um for tax year 2022 is that it's
been about a 15 $50 million positive to
the state in terms of Trends or what we
see going forward don't have a specific
answer to that other than what we've
seen historically is that the analysis
showed that it could fluctuate out of
the three factors property payroll and
sales sales is the most volatile right
it it is harder to get rid of or acquire
property in a state typically payroll
that is something you know human beings
are you either have the employees or you
don't you could have a large layoff or a
large hiring spree but that tends to
payroll tends to be a bit more um stable
sales are the most volatile um you can
have as we saw a global pandemic that
for some companies drastically reduced
their sales and for other companies they
saw significant increases in sales so I
don't know what we're going to see in
the future but I just know that sales
are
volatile um other factors that we
considered as part of these estimates as
we've talked about many times the
stimulus package ages from the federal
government put a fair amount of a bare
amount of money into the economy um that
money is in there it is doing what it is
doing but there's you know the majority
of those stimulus packages have ended
for the most
part unemployment rates and inflation
two things that I think everybody is
watching at this point um there's a
forecasted GDP growth in 24 of
2.5% and 1.9 in 25 that's compared to
2.5% in 23 so I think we're seeing some
stabilization and then maybe a bit of a
slight decline in
GDP unemployment um is forecasted to
rise nationally to 4% at the end of 24
up from 3.8% now obviously New Hampshire
is trending even lower than that
3% and then inflation this forecast
there's a variety of forecasts out there
we just picked one to show this forecast
um has 3.3% at the end of 24 which is
down about a half a percent from the
3.8% currently so what does all of this
mean we are estimating for fiscal year
24 that we would end the year at 1
b243 million which is down just 3% from
plan and this is essentially assuming
that we remain at that minus. 3% that we
are at today through May and June the
vast majority of Revenue that will come
in in the last two months will be in
estimates in June um and we've seen
estimates in um April cooling off a
little bit um and so we're kind of in
assuming that we will just kind of say
status quo as compared to plan for the
remainder of the
Year talking about fiscal year
25 um we assumed that that business
taxes would remain flat there does not
seem to be a lot of change um going on
in the economy at this point the economy
just seems fairly stable it doesn't seem
to be growing there is there's threats
of you know things may be turning down
slightly but most of the indicators that
we're seeing is just for pretty stable
revenues going into 25 the slight
increase that you'll see from the 1 b243
million to the 1
b246 million that $3 million difference
is a surplus statement item for the Dr
auditors
yeah thank you
um director the question I have is yes
yesterday or the day before Bank of
America used the
sord in one of their uh stagflation
okay that wasn't the first s word that
came
anyway well if you remember
Jimmy um
was that taken into your consideration
they were indic they they were asking I
believe in their update on um Revenue
estimates um for for Bank of America why
no one else was concerned about that at
that time was that taken into the
consideration regarding revenues and
revenue uh um
projections Bank of America statement
not
specifically but I I think in General
when we're saying kind of a 0% growth
rate going from 24 to
25 that's kind of maybe the fact that
we're feeling kind of the same way that
there's been an effort to reduce the the
inflation it has come down it is not
maybe continued to decline there's been
talks about lowering interest rates that
didn't happen at the last Federal
Reserve meeting so I think our feeling
is that it's everything's feeling like
status quo at the moment so whether you
want to use stagflation for that term or
follow up Mr
CH so the question then becomes is this
a feeling or are there objective
standards that have occurred events that
have occurred that would lend Credence
to
the apprehension that I think is
widespread both I'd say we kind of look
at a lot of you know reports we take
into account these GDP forecasts the
inflation forecasts the unemployment
forecast and then it kind of just
becomes a general feeling so it's not as
prescribed or mathematical of take you
know these specific inputs in a some
sort of formula and output a growth rate
it is more let's look at these inputs
and then how are we feeling so it's a
little a little bit of both
yeah depends on the Day represent PL I
want to go through a thought
exercise the federal government's
running about a $2 trillion deficit
every year year after year after year uh
so it's essentially printing money uh to
cover that and I'm trying to think
through the impact of that to the state
of New Hampshire uh and one uh
businesses because of inflation may very
well raise their prices which may
increase our Revenue resulting but our
costs will go up too as we reflect
inflation through what we pay uh for
various services and for labor so uh
what is the net impact of all that in
your view positive or negative or who
knows I think the answer is who knows
and I think and we've talked about this
before that New
Hampshire tax base and economy is fair
fairly diverse we have retail we have
Hospitality we have tourism we have
manufacturing we have a variet we have
Healthcare we have a variety of
Industries and
so
as increased cost or increased prices
impact various businesses in different
ways for some it's good for some it may
be not as good or bad but we have a
diverse business base so I think we can
kind of weather various storms if you
will fairly well and we've seen this in
the past that when we do have a
recession or a downturn New Hampshire
tends to not fall as far but we don't
recover as quickly because the places
the states that fall far and recover
quickly are when you have a lot of your
Revenue concentrated in certain
industries so I think because of our
diverse tax base and industries in the
state and diverse taxpayers
for some the the money that's been
infused into the economy is a good thing
and increased prices are a good thing
because they hit the bottom line for
other companies those increase prices
might be for their cost of goods sold
and that's going to be negatively
impacted on the bottom line so I think
it just comes down to the diversity of
the businesses allow us to kind of
weather the storm a little bit easier
thank you for answering an impossible
question succinctly and
nicely thank you anybody else questions
before we move
on okay I just wanted to cover quickly
representative fellow's question to
Chris that he dodged um quite
eloquently
um splitting business taxes between BPT
and
bet is one of the harder things that we
do because taxpayers pay to the
department typically bet bet and BPT
together and we need to kind of we need
to then split them apart because while
they are separate taxes they are very
much interchangeable the bet is a one
for one credit against the BPT so they
are totally interdependent if you will
on each other so what you'll be what you
are likely seeing in the revenue Focus
which I think may have sparked your
question is how bet seems to be
performing under plan while BPT is over
plan
and that is due to how we allocate the
revenue so because taxpayers will just
make fill out an estimate form and folks
like representative Aly who have been
around for a while have remembered us
attempting to get taxpayers to fill out
a specific BPT amount and a specific bet
amount and there was quite a bit of
uproar amongst the business Community
when we ask them to do that because the
taxes are so interrelated it's very hard
to do so businesses will fill out
sometimes one or the other they'll say
here's a $100 and they'll put it on the
BET
line up
until July 1 we were taking that amount
that the business put on that form and
attributing all that to bet so if they
said $100 to bet we would put that all
to bet and then when their final return
came in we would allocate the money
appropriately based on their final
return so if it ended up being $50 for
bet and $50 for BPT we would do that
allocation at the time of the return and
move the
money what we found is that
taxpayers are not very good at
estimating their split between bet and
BPT and they were just putting it all on
the BPT line or on the BET line because
if you're going to pay one tax or the
other you're going to pay bet so they
were putting all of their money on the
BET line and we were having to do all of
these reallocations into
BPT what we started on July 1 is even if
they tell us that that $100 is bet we
look at their prior year return and
split it based on their prior year
return so we are getting much more
accurate with our bet and BPT split but
we are still having to do these
reallocations based on the old
methodology of how we were allocating so
that's why you're seeing bet showing
below plan is because we are still
having to move money out of bet into BPT
especially during this time of economic
growth in the past few years and
businesses having in many cases record
profits BPT is just a is going to become
a larger portion so at the top of the
page you'll see the split is
76.4% and
23.6% it's been 6040 in the past so
we're just seeing a move towards BPT
plus coupling with how we were
allocating the revenue is why we're
looking that we're performing under the
plan for bet and that will work itself
out in the next few fiscal years as our
allocation method changes is that
terribly confusing or
helpful follow just one so when you get
to the end of the tax year are they are
is does the company square that up so
those are really tells you how much was
related to personnel and how much was
profit yep so when they file their final
return we know how much is BET and how
much is BPT and we are moving the money
within that account and within the
revenue accounts to reflect that and so
that's why you're seeing that's exactly
why you're seeing that move out of bet
and into BPT and that's why we're
showing below plan on BET represent
Alman two things one on does this mean
that the cafer will have much more more
accurate numbers in future that's our
goal our goal is to get that split more
accurate because as you remember we
would
historically just split bet and BPT on
the most recently completed tax year you
kept on doing 4060 I kept 4060 right but
now like you're you're seeing we're
closer to
7525 and so by doing it in this new
methodology we will get more accurate so
there won't be that delay in the report
reping and will'll more timely know how
the two taxes are interacting and what
we're seeing now with that shift to BPT
oh yeah and the other one because of the
way we defined the taxes when we put
them in on the on
BPT
is only the profit that a particular
very large industry gained uh but not on
their share of vet so their tax is
actually BP bet and BPT correct whereas
everybody else's tax is just the bet
because they didn't qualify or they
qualified to give you $100 right on and
so it does obscure to some extent how
heavily the different groups are being
cxed um represented play did you have a
question yes is the business profits tax
more or less volatile than other taxes
we we're
uh imposing on our
populace I don't know
okay I I I'll go back to saying we did a
really nice job estimating it and as we
get further through the presentation
you'll see we did not do as nice of a
job estimating some of the other reeven
um my my concern is that we're relying
heavily on BPT for revenues we I mean we
are I view California who uh have bumper
years and they're spending money like
crazy and then it's not so bumper and
then they have to scramble and uh
fortunately we've got a more diverse tax
base and uh most stability but still is
a concern there about volatility correct
so you're you're correct that our
Revenue Pi looks very different than
other states Revenue P because of the
lack of the income tax and the sales
tax but where our Revenue Pi relies more
heavily on our business tax our business
income tax or business taxes combined we
also have a diverse industry diverse set
of Industries so if if our Revenue Pi
looked the way it did and that the
business profits tax say was coming from
largely one specific industry we could
be facing challenges a volatility within
that tax because it's such a large
portion of the P but where that tax
generally is not terribly volatile and
you can look and I can send it to you in
our annual report you can look at how
the business taxes have grown and there
are very few years of more of double
digit change between the
taxes good to know uh represent and then
we'll continue with yeah the the other
part part of the volatility which is
more worrying I think is the small
number of businesses that pay for most
of the
tax correct if you look at our triangles
in our annual report you'll see the tip
of that triangle is a few number of
taxpayers although I think we saw during
the
pandemic that that number stayed the
same but the businesses that made up
that point of the trial triangle did
fluctuate because you had some
businesses that were highly profitable
during the pandemic and you had other
businesses that were not and so that tip
of the triangle just kind of swapped out
um with some businesses and again I
think that goes to the diversity of
Industries within our tax
base thank you uh representative Malloy
did you want to ask quick question
yes thank you thank you Mr chair in in
all of this information and and maybe
you've answered this before somewhere
but we talked about the diversity of our
business base do we have a percentage
breakdown of that or a pie chart about
who what what categories or what I know
you don't talk about individual
businesses and I'm not asking for that
I'm just talking about the categories of
that so that we can I could
see what that diversity looks like
that's all thank you so in terms of
whether we have that at Dr it's a hard
question to answer and it's something
that I've been looking at since I
started at Dr in
2010 the hard part for us is that that
information would come in on a tax
return on what's called a Nace code and
it's a code that the taxpayer fills out
that identifies what industry they're in
and you can think of large taxpayers who
operate in a variety of Industries and
they might just put industry that's
their largest in their
portfolio that's the nce code that they
use but in New Hampshire the actual
activity is from a a different industry
maybe it's a smaller subsection think
for instance a manufacturer they might
manufacture a wide variety of products
and the majority of what they
manufacture is widgets so they're going
to put I'm a widget facturer
manufacturer but in New Hampshire
they're really a gardener and they're
you know manufacturing plant plants it's
not going to totally align so we've
tried to use this data and then found it
produced results that we didn't feel
like were consistent so that's something
that we haven't totally been able to
tackle and I don't know the best way to
do that whether it's coupling with
information from either other agencies
or other groups and trying to compile it
together but it is a a great question
and something I would love to do in in
my 14 years I haven't figured out how to
do it yet followup
thank you very much for that followup uh
so before
we put any implied pressure on you to
keep going down that road this is a
question for the committee is that
information that would help us at all in
Dev
developing tax policy as a maybe
rhetorical question I address that to
the committee that's all I mean I will
say maybe one thing that we could do is
for the tip of that triangle or say the
top 100 businesses
or let me start smaller top 25
businesses we could do an anal not rely
on the nce codes but we could do
research and say okay what is what
industry would we categorize them for
their activity in New
Hampshire and we could kind of come up
with our own analysis and then maybe
expand it to the top 50 or the top 100
so it wouldn't necessarily be taxpayer
reported because of that issue that I
described and we wouldn't be able to do
it for everyone but we could do it for
some of of our larger taxpayers and it
would get us to a point we could do it
to a large enough point that we wouldn't
worry about disclosing taxpayer
information so maybe that's a a takeaway
for us thank you commissioner I
appreciate that thank you thank you
represent
ery well you're your last com comment
regarding what you could do kind brings
up two questions so I'll address that
one first 25 the top 25 is nice to know
because they produce the large largest
chunk but it's the same time we have a
diverse income
so if we're going to talk about the top
we should probably talk about the middle
25 and the bottom as to the general
category of those so we know somewhere
in there and also of that whether the
bottom of the
pyramid in its totality of of in Revenue
generation compared to the top so that
you I think for Revenue estimates going
forward yeah that would give us a better
idea as to the diversity of the the
revenue sources sure and a better
understanding of our economy agreed and
going back then to your other question
regarding the NX code or n codes yep um
yeah that that even getting the right
code is a bit of a problem at times
because that IRS is really screwed up um
well that's yeah well never mind
uh what you're saying is that a
corporation that may be involved in
building ships
there and uh heavy
equipment
here is going to be classified by
whichever one they decide to put down
correct correct so it may not be totally
representative of their the actual
industry in New Hampshire particularly
when they're by uh Manufacturing avionic
which doesn't have anything to do with
either one right and especially as we
get you know that top 25 those very
large companies have pretty diverse um
you know portfolios of businesses and so
you know it it can be hard to say what
of those is the most important here
without us doing some our own research
thank you just wanted to clarify that
thank you sure thank you I think we've
uh done a good job with uh BPT and bet
and we can move on okay here you go
Lauren
I almost forgot we were talking about
all of the taxes
today
so so uh moving on to the meals and
rentals tax so the historical breakdown
um for that this particular taxes 80% of
it comes from the meals or what I like
to call food 177% from the rooms in the
hotel industry and 3% from the motor
vehicle rentals and that 3% is what um
is used to figure figure out the
education trust fund portion of the
meals and rentals tax so the rooms and
meals stay in the general fund and the
vehicle tax stays in the education trust
fund and so when we were looking at our
revised plan for this year some of the
factors that we looked at was that
fiscal year to date we are 5.3 million
or 2% ahead of our plan um fiscal year
to date we are 7 million or 2.6 ahead of
the prior year and when we look at that
gross before the the transfers that come
off the top of that tax were actually
17.4 million ahead of the year or 4.6%
growth year-over-year so I just want to
make that clear because of the municipal
fund transfer and the school building
Aid transfer that does make the meals
and rentals tax look a little bit more
flat than what is actually happening
because the meals and um the municipal
fund transfer is based on the prior
Year's performance in the general fund
for the meals and rentals tax and that
was also a strong year so the transfer
to the municipal Revenue fund is also a
a larger
transfer and other things that we were
looking at too um is inflation impacting
the cost of meals rooms and motor
vehicles um I know throughout this year
we've heard from the restaurant industry
that a lot of what we're seeing is just
just the cost that they have to charge
for meals have gone up because the cost
of the goods to prepare meals have gone
up so where we may not necessar see more
people in restaurants what we're um
again the benefit of is the that like a
Stak costs maybe 1015 more than it might
have a couple of years ago um other
things that were we were also looking at
and this is more on um in our Northern
um counties um that 2023 was the wetest
summer on record so if someone had a
beautiful Lake vacation and they had a
re cancellable hotel and they saw the
forecast wasn't very good they may not
have come up uh as we expected also um
we had the warmest winter on record and
we had noticed that some of the activity
was down because of the lack of snow on
some of the mountains and just the
amount of work to have something skiable
this year um also what we haven't seen
yet and that will be in this month's
revenues is the impact of the total
solar eclipse on the April M&R liability
so we we um padded that in and then
other things that we took out um is the
scheduled School building Aid transfer
and the municipal Revenue fund transfer
and um that has been occurring since um
20 2022 was the first year where we um
saw that transfer coming right out of
the meals and rentals tax so with that
said um our revised estimate um is 2%
over the plan so up to
326.00 but actually it's um we're
actually uh flat over the 2% increase in
fiscal year 24 but consequently once you
increase your fiscal year 24 Revenue you
have to increase your fiscal year 25
Municipal fund transfer so when you
increase that you end up flat
year-over-year on the net revenue for
meals and rentals
tax and um before I move on to school
building Aid or the municipal fund
transfer are there any questions about
M&R represent PL I'm reading a lot of
anecdotal evidence that people are
hitting the wall uh that all the
stimulus that going into individual
pockets is pretty much gone those on
food stamps have drawn them down and so
the restaurants uh uh the prices are
higher which means more Revenue to us
but not if there's less traffic and so
is that is that taken into account in
your forecast that there might be less
traffic yes it is and um that this would
be similar
um to like the r tax where the where at
this point the higher prices will
sustain that flat growth for a little
bit until we may see in 26 or 27 um some
declines if something doesn't
fundamentally change in those Industries
and and how consumers choose to spend
their disposable
income yes representative Southworth
it's interesting I have the opposite
view of Representative PL which means
you were right to just have it in the
middle yeah um I tend to um be very
positive about the meals part I'm
noticing people really that I know have
limited income are still loving their
lattes and they're still doing the
easier takeout um they may not be going
to Wentworth by the sea but uh I've been
surprised um at the long lines at
certain places that I thought might get
shorter so I kind of see the opposite
end of and in some areas that we saw in
the meals this year where um a lot of
that growth is in the full service and
fast food services and also I I guess
this shouldn't be a surprise but for
some reason it was surprising to me
supermarkets because you would think
that there isn't a lot of taxable in
supermarkets but we do have grocery
stores and supermarkets that have a
really nice prepared food section or
deli section that where they're making
sandwiches or they're preparing pizzas
and that has just really exploded over
the last couple followup
yeah yes thank you um so I think um
another thing is I live in the sea Coast
which has been booming no matter what uh
but I also think like many of our
discussions this is an area that's
really variable in New Hampshire it just
you know like uh property taxes other
things we've talked about on this
committee I think this really very
varies greatly depending on the zip code
in the part of the state and that may
also contribute it to it being kind of
flat in the end that's correct
one other thing I'll just add quickly to
Lauren's point about seeing an increase
in full service restaurants but also
representative South War's point about
takeout is that we do have full service
restaurants that are offering more
takeout since the pandemic but also the
variety of services that will come and
deliver that take out to your house
right you have the door dashes of the
world the Uber Eats etc those are still
all showing for us in our Revenue as
full service because it is coming from a
full service restaurant even though it's
more akin to a delivery um or a takeout
and so I think the ability to to have it
delivered to your house also does reduce
the cost right the it is typically at
least least at least cheaper for me with
my children if it just gets delivered to
the house and there's not the
opportunity for an appetizer a dessert
you know and four lemonades um the the
bill is less when when I utilize those
services so I think that is something
that's impact in it as well that we
can't necessarily see in our numbers um
because it's just still showing from the
full
service um I think represent ery and
then representative
fellows thank you Mr chair uh going back
to the question I asked going to be on
the meals and
rooms um it would be interesting to know
what percentage since we're tourist
State and tourist income is important uh
which is out of state and instate and uh
previously said that there's no real way
of determining that however if you take
a it seems to me that if we could take a
look at a a diner and Conway and see how
it's going up and down would give some
idea as to whether or not there was a
tourist coming into that area um because
they only have a small population and
then they get a large you
understand that would be an an
interesting thing to to help watch The
Tourist trade come in and it's and the
other factor is regarding the three
sources of meals and rooms or meals uh
with the prepared
meals is there any way that that we
could see how that works uh diners
versus full service restaurants versus
uh um uh quick you know drive-thru
McDonald's to use a term uh versus
versus uh hanford's or Market Basket
which do make very nice
chickens I know I just had a Hanford
chicken last night for dinner and one
other one other advice make sure you
don't feed the kids for two hours before
you go
shopping so and this is going to be very
interesting very similar to the business
taxes how a um how a restaurant or a
hotel identifies is
self-reported and one thing that I've
noticed that I know there's a chain
restaurant and one location is a full
service restaurant and the other one is
a fast food but they are identical in
concept but they were registered at
different times the other thing we also
run into and um I know I've discussed
this with members of the committee we
have uni um we do have unified filing in
the meals and rentals tax so if I'm a
franchisee and I have 25 locations in
the state I can just file my one return
to my maybe my most profitable location
and all our reporting is going to be
based on that one location and that may
not be indicative of what's happening in
another region in the state so so what
so what we can say is as long as they're
consistent from year to year if you're
consistently fast food and you're
consistently in Hillsboro County I can
that that's where you file um we can say
this is what's happening but that may
not be necessarily true to Hillsboro
County if I am a restaurant that has
dozens of locations and I'm the one
owner uh franchising that yeah I had
forgotten about the unified reporting
thank you for reminding of that but the
other question is regarding the
restaurants Conway versus uh well Hudson
um I mean we're going to get traffic
from Kingsboro and L only because it's
generally cheaper even with gas but
we're not somebody's going to make a
two-hour trip to go to Conway they're in
the tourist area I think we can do that
analysis potentially this coming month
we can't go to the town level as as
Lauren mentioned but we can do it based
on the county and I think we'll see it
in coas County with the eclipse so I
think we will see for April Revenue
that's reported in May that Coos County
is going to have a disproportionate
increase in their revenue compared to
the other counties and I think we can do
a county analysis by month where you
would see the Lakes Region counties
potentially seeing an uptick in
disproportionate uptick in Revenue
during the summer season White Mountains
um you know Ski Area Counties in the
winter so I think we can can't
necessarily go to the town level but I
think we can look at the counties and
determine whether or not we're seeing
kind of a tourism impact in those
counties in any given month thank you
repr represent fellows okay thank you
thank you um
did I hear you say did I understand you
correctly to say that that things like
door Dash are being charged the room and
they pay room and meals tax on that so
yeah that's that's correct so it's not
NE the door Dash but when you place the
order to the restaurant the taxable
portion of that transaction is being
collected so so it's not the door Dash
it's not the person you're not getting
you're you're taxing the food you're not
taxing the door Dash service is that
correct correct so I just wanted to
share that every time Market Basket
builds a new store they've got that big
section now they're providing lots of
pre you know pre-made foods that the
business and the room and meals tax is
going to collect on represent PL oh I'm
sorry I didn't let you answer was there
she's correct okay yeah she's
correct may I resent PL what what
mechanism is there to uh let's see
provide some uniformity where the mil
room taxes applied and where it isn't
example uh I live in an over 55
community uh once once a year or twice a
year uh a bunch of people in the
neighborhood we buy Lobster from uh
precook from one or the grocery store
one of them applies a tax to the Lobster
when it's cooked and another
doesn't and so is if you'd like to send
us that information
[Laughter]
but the point is what what mechanism
does the state have to try to ensure
some uniformity citizens like
you we we have a Anonymous um Dr T we
call it tax fraud but Dr tax fraud um
submission form on our website um so if
you are finding that tax is not being
applied consistently you can submit that
to us anonymously or not anonymously um
that happened quite a bit when the M&R
rate changed when it went down there
were still a number of um businesses
even though we communicated as well as
we could um there were still charging
the higher rate and it was literally
everyday citizens who looked at the
receipt and said hey this looks wrong
and sent it to us and we would contact
the business and and get everything
straightened out so nice what what town
do you live in represent
elme on yes I read over a month ago now
that on the credit card debt in the
country had surpassed what it was just
at the beginning of the Great
Recession which was kind of a peak
for I think going back as far as we knew
on
and I worry uh I am seeing in my own
town it's
very Irregular at this point but when a
house happens to come on the market
on sometimes it gets bought up for what
is an incredible price and sometimes it
sits on the market for five months
because the owner thought he could also
get the incredible price and he
couldn't and and they had to wait for
him to give up on that on
and and the the housing actually the
real estate transfer tax has gone down
133% this year so far and that's got to
do with the fact that there aren't very
many houses left on the market that come
on the market that people are willing to
give up repes representative what the
question should be on meals and rentals
yes it's on it's on meals and rentals
but it's it's the same uh kind of thing
that on we're in I think we're in a
transition where a lot of people who
have been living based on
subsidies are going to credit to keep
doing that and are going to hit an wall
at some
point and I don't know how much damage
that does to us in meals and rentals in
houses and I wish it would happen to
houses in a bunch of other things I
think that's evidenced by the fact that
we're estimating that meals and rentals
tax is essentially going to stay flat
going into next year so we're coming off
of years of growth in M&R and we're kind
of forecasting that we for a variety of
reasons that have been mentioned that
we've kind of are reaching our peak in
M&R and that we anticipate it to
stabilize a
bit okay there's no more questions I'd
like to move on to the school building
Aid transfer okay so um just to quickly
remind everyone what the school building
Aid transfer is um this is a monthly
transfer that is um 112th of the fiscal
year total and and as we're slowly
paying off that debt that has come down
every year so it's only a few I I think
it was like $600,000 a month when it
used to be much greater so for fiscal
year 24 it's um
$568,000 on on um the 6.8 million in
scheduled debt and every year that will
come down until that is paid off in
fiscal year
2030 and I'm not aware of any additional
debt that is tied to the meals and
rentals tax that's in the forecast for
that further um we talked about this
earlier the municipal fund transfer and
um that
is and that is the distribution to the
cities and towns following a popula um
following a population
formula and and how that is calculated
every year that is 30% of the net income
of the most recently completed um fiscal
year and that net income is um is the
general fund revenues before the school
building Aid transfer and before um that
Year's um Municipal fund transfer so
when we look at our forecast if we
increase fiscal year 24 the next year
the mun fund transfer will also increase
based off of that so if F if um we have
a decline in one fiscal year then the
munity fund transfer the next year will
decline um
proportionally and um and what we will
so what we are estimating for fiscal so
this year this number is set and has
been uh distributed to the towns is 13.9
million and the way that we determine
how much each month to withhold um that
is just based on the
historical fluctuation in how the tax is
collected it's on a seasonal basis so
that's why you may see June is much
higher than December or January and and
how that's
determined also uh we are increasing our
what we're thinking is the estimate for
fiscal year 25 based on our revised 24
forecast we're looking at
134.5 million for next year and that of
course is always subject to change as we
go into that Revenue estimating process
um in the next
bium are there any questions so on this
table um are
July 2023 through April is that those
actual figures these are actual figures
all all the way through to June these
are the these are the scheduled
transfers so treasury um can confirmed
back um either in the late summer early
fall that the transfer this year will be
13.9 million and what we did um was we
distributed how that should come out of
the out of the general fund based on the
seasonality of how we collect the tax so
we don't find ourselves in June making
$130 million transfer or just something
a little bit more reasonable in any
given month okay thank you so that is
set questions on uh School building Aid
transfer or Municipal fund transfer
representative Aly thank you I'm a
little confused wasn't do we give the
money based on what happened the year
before every month monthly payments for
July of 23 to at are given in July
24 so the 13.9 million is the total
amount that is based on the total amount
of M&R from the prior year so the 13.9
in fiscal 24 is based on fiscal 23
Revenue we then take that 13.9 and
spread it between the months equivalent
to the proportion of Revenue that comes
in in that month so it's not an exact
July to July it's a total fiscal year to
a total fiscal year but because the
revenues for M&R do fluctuate our
highest M&R Revenue months are July
August September October and
November we apply the majority or a
larger portion of the municipal fund
transfer in those
months so we're just spreading that
transfer each month based on how
revenues historically come
in follow
up and
I but the towns are getting the money
every month right the towns get them one
payment in the fall they do and we're
just this is just our the way out right
this is sits in a fund corre then they
get it once correct they actually get it
the fund goes negative and we take the
rest of the year to replenish the
fund Yep they're getting in one payment
okay representative rord yes thank you I
just a a couple of questions one on each
page here the first one is I think
probably an easier question um it's well
at least I can ask it easier I don't um
on the meals and rooms Municipal Revenue
transfer do we have data do we have you
have a breakdown kind of H uh revenue
generated by Town versus how much
they're getting we're not able to
provide that and that goes back to my
answer to representative ol earlier
where we do have the UniFi the unitary
filers so when you have somebody who has
25 plus licenses one town is getting all
the credit for all those licenses
throughout the state so this is um I
don't have the exact lawn for me but it
is a based on the population I I that
another agency um maintains okay great
and then by the school building transfer
um and bear with me I'm trying to ask
the question so I don't really know what
question I want to ask but uh I I I'm
just looking at the bond payments are
going down I'm assuming that's because
we're not building any
schools and we haven't built the state
hasn't you know participated in any of
building Aid uh for a number of years
which leads me to my I mean and and so
that's my assumption one so you can stop
me if that's uh that's wrong but the
second part oh go ahead I'll say it's um
yes and no why you're not seeing it go
up is that there hasn't been any new
debt taken out but what you are seeing
is a typical pay down schedule from that
debt that was taken out in 2009 okay and
so what you're seeing is over time the
interest payments go down but also just
the way and I I'm sure treasury can talk
to this better than I can just the way
the debt is structured it is based on um
one principal payment a year and two
interest payments a year and they have
different coupons at different rates so
the amount that you pay per fiscal year
that is set in stone the day you close
on that Bond and it goes to sale okay
and that will go down just because we
are paying it off so so that kind of
it's not fixed so that leads and that
answers part of my question um the other
part is so just to understand so we're
we're when we do build schools and we
are giving state aid that's debt we do
that through debt or are we taking money
out of the treasury to do that as well
or is there a combination of
that so the school building a Debt
Service you're seeing in the meals and
rooms relates to um money that was
bonded by the state at the start of the
Great Recession so in 2009 2010 2011 the
state bonded the um building Aid amounts
that was paid to the communities instead
of paying out of the general fund or
some other fund so that's being paid
down right now so that's separate than
the building aid program there is still
a building aid program um that the state
provides funding for that is run by the
Department of Education and schools are
ranked um based on the type of building
that they want to do the need that they
have in their community and doe keeps
that um that ranking so and and it's
capped at $50 million and you may hear
something about a tail payment that's
Bond payments back to the commun
community excuse me state aid back to
the community to help them with their
bond payment to the buildings that they
have bonded so that answers my question
thank you very
much repres El glad I could help I'd
just like to add to that that on we made
that decision at the beginning of the
Great Recession on there was in place a
much more generous Municipal uh School
building aid program uh which was only
accessible to the Richer communities
that could get bonds through their
populace and um they had um they had
been on the list they were promised this
money and the Great Recession
hit and we should not have bonded that
money it wasn't something you should
Bond but we also should not have have
forfeited the promise that had been made
to those communities to get the money
and uh Finance decided to bond the money
any other questions on these two areas
representative fellows uh yes my
question is about page six about the the
room and
meals transfer and how that's paid it
did is what's going on is you look at
the um total amount that was raised from
room and meals for FY
23 and it came to
13.9
million
and that is distributed to the towns
sometime in
fy4 and then these figures I see on the
page are those just what you're using as
um amounts to for your financial
reporting to what are this is to
reimburse the fund for those
distributions to the to the m uh to the
municipalities so this is what was
dedicated and the decision was made that
each month we would make a transfer
equal to the amount that went out to the
municipalities in fiscal year 24 and
instead of having one month have 130
million go out and go negative in that
way we spread it out over the course of
the fiscal year based on the seasonality
of how collections come in so in this
fiscal year right now you've been
transferring money to treasury because
treasury kind of like fronted the
payment for so the last day of the month
so if you look at those daily reports
that we send out in the back end of the
month you'll see on the last business
day that M&R will decrease significantly
and that's because you're seeing the mun
fund transfer go
out oh okay um said another way there's
essentially a one-year lag in US funding
the payment so in fiscal 24 we're
funding the payment that was made for
fiscal
23 well so so I understand that's what
you're doing I'm just wondering why it's
being done that
way because you we don't know the final
number for fiscal 23 until the fiscal
year
closes so we don't know this 13.9
million till after the fiscal year has
already closed and as Lauren mentioned
we spread the amounts throughout the
year because otherwise
you would take the whole hit of the 13.9
million that we need to take out of M&R
we don't want to take it just in one
month so we do it throughout the year so
that the revenues are more consistent
and you don't and essentially prevents
us from panicking in July when it looks
like we're
13.19 million under
plan right representative ORS thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question so just for clarification your
monthly allocation is based on the
business that you anticipate pay for
that month correct thank
you okay seeing no more questions we'll
move on to tobacco tax page seven
tobacco
tax okay um
so basical year 24 year-to date
breakdown we uh revenues are 83% from
cigarette stamps and 177% from other
tobacco products so that is your loose
tobacco and also your ecigarettes
fiscal year to date we are 17.9 million
or 10.1% below
plan we are 20.2 million or
11.2% below prior year fiscal year to
date through April stamp sales are down
15% from fiscal year 23 so what does
this all mean basically we're seeing a
shift um in consumption to other tobacco
products from cigarettes
in particular we're seeing a shift to
ecigarettes and ecigarettes are taxed
differently than traditional cigarettes
and taxed differently than other tobacco
products and they're essentially taxed
at a lower rate so as people move from
traditional cigarettes to ecigarettes
or people start taking up a cigarette
habit and they utilize ecigarettes where
historically
people would start smoking cigarettes
this whole move to ecigarettes is having
an impact on
revenues um we mentioned when we did the
presentation so I just wanted to mention
it again at the time there was talk of a
national ban on flavored tobacco
products we did see an increase in New
Hampshire revenues um when Massachusetts
baned flavored tobacco products we saw a
lot of people come across the border to
make those purchases here in New
Hampshire that has tapered off a bit as
folks have learned they can also utilize
the internet to make those purchases and
have things come directly to their house
as opposed to having to drive to New
Hampshire um but that National ban um
has been placed on indefinite hold so we
are not anticipating that at this time
but we did talk about during Revenue
estimating so I wanted to mention it so
where do we think fiscal year 24 is
going to end um we um estimate that the
year year difference um from prior year
will remain for the rest of the year
which would have us ending at
191.000 and then I'll say that for 25
this was one of our the harder ones to
estimate um this estimate here of
189.1 which results in 10.6% below plan
is a minus 1% over what we've seen in 24
so obviously year to date we're seeing
significant decline over prior year and
then what we're saying is that that's
basically going to only be a 1% decline
next
year that might be a bit optimistic I'm
not really sure this is one of the
harder ones for us to estimate but we've
seen a significant decline in tobacco
over the past couple years and part of
me feels like it's just going to kind of
even out I think we've seen the increase
from the pandemic where a lot of people
smoked more than they did previously and
also the impact of that Massachusetts
band we've kind of come down for that
and I I think we're going to right size
a bit but that 25 estimate is a tough
one just for context if it's helpful
very rough
analysis
[Music]
um cigarettes
um so sorry let me start with
ecigarettes E ecigarettes are sold in
one of two ways either a Clos system
which is what you would consider like a
vape pen it is a a device that looks
almost like a pen you cannot open it and
when it's done you throw it away that's
a closed system an open system is where
you purchase the liquid and you include
it in your own device um that those are
taxed
differently um the closed system and
open systems trying to compare them to
cigarettes roughly when you're talking a
closed system so one pen is roughly
5,000 Puffs 5,000 Puffs is the
equivalent to 20 packs of cigarettes so
one pen is about 20 packs of cigarettes
and one fill up one liquid of an open
system is roughly 6,000 Puffs so it's a
little bit of rough math but basically
one fill up of an open system one closed
system those equal 20 packs of
cigarettes again rough average math
costs vary by vendor and store and
various other things but an open system
one fill up that you you would pay 52
cents in tax currently a closed system
you would pay roughly $4 in
tax and then the equivalent 20 packs of
cigarettes would be over $35 in tax so
you're looking at 50 cents
$4
$35 so this move to ecigarettes is large
contributing to this this reduction that
you're seeing in
revenues that could potentially affect
tax policy yeah sounds like our tax
revenue is going up in smoke
huh yeah be you
too representative Aly yeah
um it sounds like you think that the
Menthol bump is still there
from
Massachusetts I think we've seen that
come and go I think we've seen the
increase in the flavor band in
Massachusetts gave us an increase in
Revenue here in New Hampshire people
were coming across the border um but I
think they many people maybe it's been
effective in Massachusetts and folks
have stopped um utilizing flavored
tobacco products or like I mentioned
they found other places to get um their
products I think largely internet you do
think it has so I think that has kind of
right sized um and that we've come back
down I think we are still potentially
getting some revenue from it but if the
large I think the vast majority of
impact of a flavor ban is on your
ecigarettes
right and as we just talked the the
revenue there is just so much less than
a traditional cigarette that it's yeah
not making up that is something else I
wanted to bring up on other tobacco
products used to mean on things that you
chewed and left in your in your cheek
all day in school uh and uh pipe
tobacco and things like that and it
wasn't very much and I think it's time
to separate out ecigarettes
so we do we trap them separately and
they are taxed separately but we don't
see them separately is what I'm I'm
saying except where you're talking about
it now so on when we put in the tax for
ecigarettes
uh this body on spent a lot of time
developing a fair tax we thought and
then uh it got sent to the Senate and
the Senate cut it down by about 10
times
uh and I think it's worth us trying to
fight that battle again because it is
addictive it does hurt young people
particularly and um and it's hurting our
revenues I will say there is um a bill
currently I believe in house Commerce
for um a study committee or commission
depending on what version passes to
study um the taxation of ecigarettes so
I think there there is an opportunity if
that bill passes to do do that
representative
elberger thank you Mr chair and thank
you for uh taking my question slash
comment so if we look at the difference
between $35 for 20 packs of cigarettes
and $4 which is the higher number then
we're looking at about
85% for
the got that wrong under 10% somewhere
in there for the revenue that we're
getting from
taxes that that's your y looks like we
may have some bills to file next year
and just
to educate the committee um so the tax
rate on a pack of cigarettes is $1.78
that's evidenced by a stamp that the
wholesalers AFF fixed to the pack of
cigarettes Clos system cigarettes those
ones that are the pen all-in-one system
those are taxed at 30 cents per
milliliter open systems when you're just
buying the liquid that is 8% of the
wholesale sales price and then remaining
other tobacco products like pipe tobacco
chew I don't know those other things um
65.0 3% of the wholesale sales price and
that 65.0 3% seems like a strange number
and it is a little bit and that's
because when um the tobacco tax went in
in were taxing cigarettes and other
tobacco products the wholesale sales
price percentage was determined to be
somewhat equivalent to the stamp rate as
the stamp rate changed the other tobacco
products rate changed at the same
percent so if the stamp rate went down
by 5% the other tobacco products rate
went down by 5% and that's how you end
up with that weird 65.0 3 it's because
it's a function of a percentage
change Senator Lang thank you I was just
going to so it's it's Senate bill um 443
is the one that's uh a 433 rather that
is I don't know why it came out of ways
and means on our side but on your side
it went to Commerce um but it's to it's
to establish a study committee to look
at even the industry itself is having
some problems with tax with what's going
on with taxing the way they're taxing
and what's going on so um they've even
asked and supported this new commission
to look at that ecigarette tax rate and
how being applied and and to the
commissioner's point so just know that
that it's currently sitting in
representative Hunt's committee and if
you have a view on tobacco tax you may
want to go have a conversation with him
thank
you
433 thank you and I believe there's a
work session
tomorrow I
think representative
elme representative hunts work sessions
include 50 bills
that are listed without order but anyway
um yeah this do you
on do you know who is supposed to be on
that
Commission because we need
representation sure give me one second
I'll tell you what the bill has so
members of the commission
are three members of the House one
member of De ra one member of The Liquor
Commission two members appointed by the
governor uh plus one
Senator so I would suggest that the
chair uh go to the speaker and tell him
that we should be the members from the
house I don't see maybe one from
Commerce that's a you problem not a me
problem yeah right
that was HB 443 four no SB 433 433 433
okay no pass the Senate came over to the
house
okay okay um if there's no more
questions we'll move on to interest and
dividends tax interest and dividends
okay so um even though it's called the
interested dividends tax it's more than
just interest and dividends that are
taxed so I always like to start with the
the
breakdown so tax year 2021
47.5% of the tax was taxable annuities
are actual cash and property
distributions 38.1% was dividend income
99.2% was interest income and 5.2% was
federal tax exempt interest income so
interest income that's exempt federally
but taxed here in New Hampshire that's
tax year 21 I will say for tax year 22
the numbers are still preliminary but we
are seeing distribution a decrease in
distributions um dividend income is see
seeing um kind of a flat change but
interest income is going up and that
makes sense with the higher interest
rates we saw a very busy April at Dr um
largest number of documents on any
single day that we had to process and
largest number of calls that we received
in any single day largely with questions
from indd filers who have are have
tripped the thresholds this year due to
increased interest income so that's
where a vast majority of the growth I
guess I would say is coming from so
fiscal year to date we are 56.7 million
or
54.2% ahead of
plan 34 million or
26.7% ahead of Prior year I will say I
think some of that variation from plan
is that we weren't sure what was going
to happen in the economy at the time
that we were doing Revenue estimates and
we anticipated some bit of a economic
slowdown and maybe a decline in the
interest rates and we just haven't seen
much of that so distributions are still
good and interest is still good and
that's driving our change compared to
plan um as you all know but as a
reminder hb2 from 2023 accelerates the
repeal of the interest in dividends tax
starting at 4% for the tax year that
just ended in December that will go to
3% for the tax year year that we are
currently in that ends on December 31st
of 2024 and then the tax is repealed for
tax periods beginning on or after
January 1 of
25 so our estimate for fiscal year 24 is
actual revenue for the first 10 months
with actual revenue from the prior year
for the last two months even though we
are a bit ahead of plan or sorry
significantly ahead of plan and fairly
significant ahead of Prior year the
remaining Revenue in this year is
estimate payments and our estimate
payments in April tracked very similar
to our estimate payments last April and
so we if you assume that that Trend
continues into June estimates we just
used last year's revenue for May and
June looking at fiscal year
25 we assumed that this growth would
essentially stop that it would be flat
year-over-year growth
um and that but then we had to start
applying that rate decrease and the
ultimate repeal so you'll see the fiscal
25 number of
109.5 is essentially assuming
everything's flat but we got to take
into account that repeal so we um that's
how you end up going down to
109.5 which is still 10.1% ahead of the
plan that we were originally assuming
for 25
representative
Southworth thank you for taking my
question could you remind me um what
makes the annuity taxable what's kind of
the dividing line oh let me get you that
information we have a handy dandy
checklist on our form there many types
of annuities correct so let me it's
fairly lengthy but we can get I'll get
you a copy okay that's fine thank
you yes representative sorry oh yeah
follow um you could probably save time
basically another way to phrase it is
are most people's annuities
taxable yes okay I would say largely yes
but it it's I usually have it printed
and I didn't bring it with me today but
it's a nice checklist that goes on our
form so I'll make sure you get a
copy representative
leapley thank you um we spent a lot of
time talking about some of our other
taxes
um looking at this year's Revenue we we
also talked about the diversity of um
payers into the business profits and
business Enterprise tax I'm looking more
at all of our Revenue um as a
portfolio and I see a lot of our
revenues went down this year or were at
least below plan um whereas this was
very much above plan and really kind of
Saved our bacon so I am surprised that
we haven't talked about our over overall
um kind of portfolio diversity as a
state and the fact that we're we're
losing this um one of our charges as a
committee is to pay attention to the
health of the treasury and so I just
want to raise my concerns about the
health of the treasury going forward um
because of how this is kind of PL panned
out this year our very last slide does a
nice comparison of all the tax types
compared to plan for 24 and for 25 and I
think that'll be a nice way to see those
that are underperforming those that are
overperforming and will give you a
better feel as a whole for at least the
taxes that Dr collects how the health of
the treasury overall for dr's portfolio
of taxes so that's the very last slide
we'll talk through that and that only
goes through 2025 correct and if I
understand correctly we still have half
kind of half a year of income because of
the way the fiscal year Works am I
getting that right so there's two months
remaining in this fiscal year okay um
with the June 30th end um but kind of
what you're think about is the
legislature turns over halfway through
fy2 so I'm thinking about the repeal oh
sorry in December okay and so in 2025
you're you're noting that we'll we still
have like six months of income correct
coming from this tax correct and so when
we do the revenue estimate to come up
with the
109.5 we do look at how the revenue
comes in within the fiscal year and what
tax years that's attributed to so April
is a good example we have returns and
extensions that we receive in April and
that was for the tax year that ended in
December but also in April we received
estimate payments for the tax year that
we're currently in and so that's why the
revenue doesn't end abruptly when the
tax is repealed because there's
essentially a delay in receiving those
returns and extensions and estimates
come in early so we Factor all of that
in and do the analysis of how much
revenue we're receiving for each tax
year when we come up with these
estimates thank you I think that the I
just want to make one more statement
because the point I'm trying to make is
although you're providing us with
projections that take us through
2025 correct you know I plan on living
in New Hampshire after
2025 um
so you know we're facing a cliff that
we're not talking about today and we're
not really going to talk about
until we look at the budget for the
future so I just i' want to underline
that we spent a lot of time talking
about taxes that are worth like a third
or a sixth of this number that we're
just skipping over so I just want to
make that say that out loud for people
who are watching at
home representative elme uh thank you
this is just going back to
annuities on I believe that Mo almost
all of that uh is the parts that are
taxable are the parts that you haven't
didn't already pay taxes on correct when
the annuities got set
up but
um to speak to representatively please
com comment I think I said on the floor
before that this tax is the only one
besides small consumption taxes that
gets paid by on very wealthy people who
moved into the state after creating
their wealth
um and they do use State
Services represent ORS thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
so having done budgeting like you're
doing here and estimating on millions
and billions of
dollars would you let us know if you
thought we were going off off a
financial cliff would you be able to
look at that in the future and be able
to make it determine if you thought we
were going to fall over to Cliff with
all the Lemmings
or well I think the the determination of
going over the cliff you have to look at
both the revenue side and the
expenditure side right that you got to
take both into account so we're only
going to talk to this committee
generally about the revenue side and
then you're going to as a legislature
work with the finance committee on the
spend side so I guess the cliff is
somewhat relative when you put those two
together and that's what Chris Shay
likes to do
um
so
that's and the LBA does a very nice job
throughout the budget process of kind of
providing a nice summary of what if your
Revenue estimates look like versus your
spending estimates and so we have not
looked at fiscal years 26 and 27 in this
presentation that would be part of the
budget process that will kick
off in the fall we'll start follow about
that follow up so just to re-emphasize
maybe the question is there something
that's keeping you awake at night as you
look through these numbers say oh my
gosh all of
it or should I save that for
Chris I'll just say
it's this I think this year in
particular
has
been um notable to me in a number of
ways one as I mentioned earlier how
close we are to the business tax
estimate I don't remember the last time
that we were so close but we're also off
quite a bit with tobacco you know below
plan and we'll talk about real estate
transfer tax quickly at the end that is
below plan as well and then you know as
we're discussing indd is performing
ahead of plan and I think that this has
been essentially the some of the more
challenging Revenue new estimating that
we've done in recent years um because
it's you know I don't think any of us
during the pandemic would have said Yep
this pandemic is just going to propel us
into unprecedented economic growth right
and we're going to be in a prolonged
state of economic growth so it's just
all of it's just surprising yeah so
you've been in in this Dr for 14 years
how long have you been uh commissioner
uh since December of 2017 seven years
thank you I I think I have faith in
you pleas someone thank you I think
let's um let's move on to communication
Services
tax right not nearly as exciting as
everything else we've discussed so um so
um looking at the communication Services
tax fiscal year to date we are a half a
million or 2% ahead of plan and fiscally
year to date we are um just a little bit
over a half a million or 2.4% ahead of
the prior so basically it's been
relatively stable this tax and some of
the things that we have been looking at
and I've been drilling into is the
taxability of the video conferencing and
the use of product of that those kind of
products as people are shifting away
from the work from home and doing more
time back in the office and also
noticing that decrease in the use of
voice over Internet Protocol or VoIP and
and obviously what we've been talking
about a long time that decrease in
traditional telephone
so with that said what I have been
noticing is that there has been some um
and more recently some decreased
liabilities from these taxpayers and
also using some credits that were on
account so some there is a little bit of
credit carry forward because the way
this tax is paid is you make an estimate
in the month in which you're incurring
the liability and then you're supposed
to true it up the next month but
sometimes um people just want to give us
money and there's no Rhyme or Reason why
that's the case
so as a result um we are not revising
our estimate for fiscal year 24 or 25
because there's a little bit of risk
that we might eat up that half a million
that we are ahead right now and I we
don't see anything that would indicate
any major changes in this area okay
thank
you if there are no questions on this
tax we will move on to the real estate
transfer tax which might create a few
more questions so real estate transfer
tax tax we are 22.5 million or 12.9%
below plan fiscal year to date we are
also 29.4 million or
16.2% below prior year this is net of
the $5 million transfer to the
affordable housing
fund why are we below plan um there is
an inven inventory shortage cost of
building is high so new homes are not
being built and then also just a lower
affordability um Factor so the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors
actually publishes this this statistic
that we've included in here about a
housing affordability index and as an
example of index of 120 would mean that
the median income in New Hampshire is
120% of what is necessary to qualify for
a median priced home so median income
compared to median priced home under the
prevailing interest rates for March that
affordab affordability index was
59% so the median income is only 59% of
what you would need to qualify for um a
mortgage for a median priced home which
in New Hampshire I think just crossed
over $500,000 in this past
month um for a single family home and
it's just over $400 almost 410,000 for a
condo and those are from the March
numbers um mortgage rates are uh
7.51% for a 30-year fixed at the end of
April and that is obviously the highest
that we've seen in some
time so what do we expect for fiscal
year 24 we expect that the
year-over-year uh growth or decline of
16 and a half% will
continue and then again this was another
tough one for
25 um I just kept the number flat from
24 to 25 I do hope that mortgage rates
will ease up a little bit that we will
see some more inventory hit the market
we will know better in the next few
months the winter in New Hampshire is
slow for realtors the spring and summer
is when we typically see houses start to
come onto the market and to move um so
we will have a better idea um going into
to the
fall um but we we've just kept it
flat um I think if interest rates ease
up at all that will also help and I
think we discussed during the revenue
estimating process that there is a fair
amount of anecdotal evidence out there
or anecdotal stories of people are
they're waiting they want you know they
want to buy they've been sitting in what
was supposed to be their starter house
for much longer than they anticipated
but something things got to give before
they're able to enter the market either
there we need to have the inventory on
the market to sell or the building has
to increase and certainly the interest
rates need to come down to make it more
affordable for
folks questions representative fellows
um I just this is a difficult um thing
to try to Pro predict but my thought is
that the mortgage rate really isn't very
important because the the main issue is
that there are very few homes available
to buy and and that most of the people
who are buying them are not getting a
mortgage you know so I I don't know that
those factors are important so I don't
see any
change I just don't think that will I
don't think that's a major factor in
what's going to happen so the only the
only way
to get more sales is is probably to have
more uh inventory new inventory created
I would think I understand what you're
saying in that the the homes that are
coming on the market are going to go to
those that are able to pay cash I think
to the extent that they the inventory
really did get to a point where there
was excess inventory that's where you're
going to see the mortgage rates creating
a problem because those folks who can't
pay cash would need a mortgage and they
would buy if it were not for the
mortgage rates so I
think it they the mortgage rates could
hamper our acceleration in the real
estate transfer tax if the inventory
starts to come online but again to your
point we can't collect the tax if the
house doesn't sell so if there's nothing
to sell there's no tax to collect and
we've talked routinely in this committee
about the balance between you can
sustain a higher real estate transfer
tax on fewer transactions if the price
is High um and you can sustain the real
estate transfer tax on lower price
transactions if you have the higher
volume so it's always the balance
between the two
but I think what we're hearing more and
more lately is it's it's just the
inventory that there are people on the
sidelines even with cash to your point
where the mortgage rate might not matter
but there's just nothing for them to buy
there's no inventory there
representative Malloy thank you Mr chair
thank you what would you believe that
everything you've just said is accurate
and true I hope
so uh so uh I I spent about an hour
yesterday with the uh
finance committee and the the revenue
committee Rockingham County part of my
job and we spent a good portion of that
meeting talking about the real estate
transfer tax I would just like to add
that I would emphasize what I heard
yesterday was it's about the number of
transactions that are going on is what I
heard from the people in Rockingham
County yes high prices and interest
rates and all and inventory
which does then affect the number of
transactions and that's what they seem
to be most concerned about the number of
transactions would you believe thank you
I would I and and like I said we've
discussed for a long time about the
balance between the two and this is
probably one of the first times where I
just outright said it's a volume problem
at this point it's a volume problem and
it's a volume problem that the price
can't
fix representative Lee Le thank you
would you believe that there's a bill
sitting on the table in the house uh 454
that would address this problem it came
out of this commission out of this
committee excuse me by doubling the
amount that goes into the affordable
funding affordable housing fund that you
just mentioned that $5 million goes into
currently and um I would encourage
members of this committee who are
concerned about our stagnant um
inventory and the fact that that people
can't buy or sell and therefore our
revenue is not is has really been
impacted by this and the projection that
we're hearing is that our Revenue will
be will continue to be affected by our
lack of inventory so I would ask members
of this committee to consider asking
their leaders to vote to untable that
bill so that we can learn more about how
that might uh from a policy perspective
persective we might be able to address
this um that might help us increase our
revenues going forward since we know
we're going to be missing $86 million
from the IND tax thank
you let's try to let's try to keep this
to a Dr update I I understand members
have passions on certain things given
the time given the time is 12:30 and we
still have a little more to do here uh
representative uh Aly followed by
fellows yes can I ask a question about
uh the assessment
Bureau or is that too far off topic uh
the relationship to
this on
the on people are starting to wonder on
I live in a house that was assessed at
239,000
on 100 uh whatever it is
239,000 I guess on and on my neighbor
bought for
500 um and then the next neighbor bought
uh sold for 500 and the next neighbor
sold for four
470 after waiting five months CU he
wanted 500 and on when we get to
assessing are we going to access all of
our properties on at this new level that
is only available to a very small number
of
buyers or how is the assessing going to
be done isn't this really a town town
the assing town issue but it's part of
the
Dr and well we monitor the assessor so
the assessing is done at the Town level
and to the extent that assessments
deviate significantly from market value
then that's where our Equalization
Bureau comes in and produces an
equalization ratio every year so that
towns know how far their assessments are
off of market value the real estate
transfer tax flow is always going to be
collected on the sales price so it is a
a strictly sales price calculation that
I understand I just think we're heading
toward cliff on that issue well and
remember too with the assessed value is
that there's two there's two sides to a
calculation when it comes to your
assessed value if your assessed value
increases 20% and that is the average
increase in the assessed value in your
community and there is no increase to
your budget there will be no no change
to your tax
bill Dr has been working hard over the
years to educate Property Owners on that
and that a a straight increase to your
assessed value does not mean that same
percentage increase to your property tax
bill it's you need to look at your
relative increase to the average and you
also should attend your town meeting and
participate in the budget that's going
to be passed in your town um so it's
it's two sides to the equation yeah
right
thank you so what is I have two
questions what is the real estate
transfer tax rate and my second question
is if somebody were to buy a property
and then build um apartments on that
property and they keep it and those are
rentals they obviously pay the transfer
tax when they buy the the uh land or
whatever there is it correct that when
there all those apartments are built
there's really no real estate tax
involved at that point correct so the
real estate transfer tax is a150 per
thousand and half of that is paid by the
buyer and half of that is paid by the
seller so 75 cents per ,000 by the buyer
75 cents per thousand by the seller it
is only it only happens when the real
estate is transferred so when it is sold
so if you buy a piece of undeveloped
land for $30,000
and you build a $5 million house on it
we're going to collect the real estate
transfer tax on the $30,000 and we will
collect nothing else until that changes
hands or is sold again at the five
million right at that point the town
will start collecting correct the local
Revenue based on the assessed value
right y yeah okay any more qu yes
Senator thank you Lindsay great
presentation um on on the real estate
transaction the one thing I will say
when you're talking about mortgage uh
and you're talking about mortgage rates
the interest rate makes a huge
difference in your monthly payment right
so again so when you're dealing with
affordable housing and you have a 7%
mortgage rate on a $450,000 loan you're
looking at $29.93 for a payment but that
same mortgage rate at 3% uh this that
mortgage payment at 3% is only
$1,800 right so that's the impact of
what a mortgage means when we're talking
about people's ability to afford a house
so even right now our problem with with
transaction the number of transaction we
have is a combination of a high mortgage
rate salaries may or may not have gone
up but they haven't kept up with the
mortgage rate and pricing people out of
homes with their average mortgage
payment um and so the mortgage rate
represented the fellow's point is
extremely important in the number of
transactions we have because people
aren't qualifying because the rate's so
high and they have a $29.93 payment
instead of an $1,800 payment and what I
may be able to do the $1,800 payment but
I can't do the $22,900 payment and so
that that's one of the major impacts
which we talk about how that is not a
big factor I think it's a huge Factor we
have inflated prices and inflated
interest rate which is pricing people
out of the market which is reducing our
number of transactions right until both
those we could maybe survive an
increased um cost of a house but we
can't survive increase of of mortgage
rates on top of the increased cost um so
I just want to be careful of that and
and when we talk about affordable
housing interest rate plays a huge
impact because the what's defined as an
affordable house is based on your
percentage of income which is based on
the mortgage rate and your monthly
payment and so what could be an
affordable house for one person now is
out of out of their range because of the
7% and and you know we were in the
Senate looking at the r we actually
reduced it because we were concerned
about the out of control inflation rate
and out of control um increase prices so
I don't know that again we're not going
to solve that problem here today um but
I do think it's going to continue into
our next cycle unless we see mortgage
rates slow down and and come down and
then you never mind the fact you have
someone like me singing in a three
three-bedroom house with by myself I'm
not going to give up my 2.9% mortgage to
go take a 7% mortgage so my house isn't
going on the market which normally we
would see but it's not going to happen
as long as the mortgage rates are as
high as they are so just and I think
that's what that statistic that 59%
affordability injects from the Realtor
Association that's their their way of
kind of synthesizing exactly what you
just said right take the median income
median home price and the interest rate
and what does that mean and right now it
means your a median income only gets you
59% of what you need to buy a
house thank you representative ORS thank
you Mr chair I just wanted to thank the
gentleman from the other side of the
wall for a very clear and pithy uh
statement thank you representa Aly yes
uh that is why
uh the affordable housing community
doesn't build houses or get involved in
building houses at this point it's
mostly rental units and then it's part
of the business model of the the uh
transaction to try and figure out how to
to um Finance it but it doesn't come
down to the level of what the rents
are okay okay yes again so we talk about
the the affordable the the invest in h
fund that we were talking about earlier
again I talked to a developer and
represent mom who was up in your area
who's backed out got to invest in age
funds but backed out because the cost of
materials the cost of Labor the cost of
everything is so high that the price of
the house is so high that it no longer
meets due to the interest rates what
would qualify as an affordable house and
so you can't give them enough money to
even build a house uh as a developer so
it's a it's a it's a little C we're kind
of run chasing our tail a little bit but
just understand that even with the100
million investment or $110 million
investment we did in invest NH Builders
and developers are still not building
affordable houses because of the
interest rates they can't they would
have to price the house so high that
they would no longer qualify due to the
interest rates uh where they might have
a person who qualifies for the house if
it was lower back at the 2.9% versus the
um 7% so again I think we're kind of
little chasing our tail here but I'm not
sure we can buy our way out with the
best and H money either representative
elberger thank you Mr chair with all due
respect to all my colleagues and to be
clear I'm pretty heavily involved in the
nasua Affordable Care movement and
concerns I don't think that this is the
time or place to be discussing this
thank
you with that we will move on to the
utility property tax almost there
y almost there so uh the utility
property tax we are we are revising our
plan up
99.8% for fiscal year 24 and then um we
are keeping the fiscal year 25 plan
unchanged and some of the factors that
we were looking at is that fiscal year
to date we are 4.1 million or 12.7%
ahead of our plan we are also 15.2% of
over the prior Year and that increase in
Revenue compared to the prior and plan
is due to increased
valuations and also on what was
collected last year was reduced by
taxpayers who had um credit carryovers
or carry forwards that were applied in
fiscal year 23 so that's where you why
you're seeing that uh double digit
growth but however for 25 um other
things that we need to take into
consideration is that some property
values May decline due to changes in
economic conditions and we might have
new taxable property that could be
constructed or we can have taxable
property come offline so we're leaving
that flat so for 24 that plan that we is
we're just recognizing the actual to
date and keeping the plan unchanged for
May and June and 25 is no change from
plan and do we have any questions for
utility property tax thank you I'm going
to take a maximum of two questions on
this one and so we can move on to the
final page yes represent fellows so um
and the utilities that are are taxed is
any of that coming from solar
installations to the extent that it is
qualified as a utility under the
definition of utility and the utility
property tax it would yes anybody else
okay we stayed under the two person
limit all right Dr revised estimates
okay so last page as I mentioned this
just summarizes everything onto one page
so you will see um for and again this is
just for the taxes that Dr collects you
will see that for fiscal year 24 our
revised estimates um result in 10.8
million ahead of plan or a half a
percent and then in 25 we're estimating
that we would be under planned by 57.2
million or
2.6% so again just a nice place to kind
of see all of Dr taxes together in one
place you can see the comparisons to
plans so you can see those taxes that
are performing above plan and those that
are performing below plan or at
plan thank you any questions on this
page seeing none thank you very much
thank
you excellent
and now we will invite uh Mr Chet back
up to as promised I'd clean up at the
end so I just want to take you again
back to the revenue Focus that I handed
out at the start of the meeting I had
quickly pointed to the first table on
page one and then a table on page
three there's a number of tables on page
two
so you talk about your red analysis
it'll show you some information as the
as the revenues come in for that the
meals and rooms and the distributions
associated with that so these things all
connect to the presentation that Dr was
providing you and then your business tax
refunds on the bottom of the fourth page
there's a new table it's the primary
Comm components of your other Revenue so
we've identified that interest in
dividends is uh far exceeding plan other
revenue is also far exceeding plan but
it's not a sustainable and the reason
for that is that it's cash that's in the
bank right now that treasury has a lot
of arpa funds a lot of um uh education
trust fund balance and rainy day fund
balance those monies that they're now
earning interest is now helping your
general fund and other funds with the
um with the other revenue and you can
see if you look at that table on the
bottom of page four excuse me page three
I'm sorry
um yeah I'm sorry I'm you you can see
that the interest revenue on surplus
funds is at 80.7
million plan was only $25.8
million so as you start to spend down
the arpa funds that sit in the bank
you're going to see the interest Revenue
start to go
away the bottom of page three
I said four just to see if people were
paying attention
but
yes so again that was one of it's one of
those revenues that's been doing very
well it's been helping keep the um
plan
ahead along with that if you were to
look at the insurance tax that's ahead
of plan by about $22.3
million part of the reasons for that is
your um Property and Casualty um you
know your automobile and house
homeowners insurance is up as the uh
cost to replace those types of things is
up so the premiums are up on those types
of insurances as well as in the medical
side of it there was some um
conservative estimates early on by the
insurance department around the medical
aspects because they didn't know how
some of the um new technologies were
going to impact the the markets and
those Technologies being things like new
medicines that are pretty expensive or
treatments that are pretty expensive and
how those might um be used or not used
if given a choice as well as um the um
Professional Care has been real has been
higher than it has been typically in the
past so those are some reasons why
you've seen the insurance premium tax um
doing better than
planned um I'd like to note as well that
your uh transfer from The Liquor
Commission is trending downward the last
couple of months some of that may be the
effort of people to um drink less
alcohol consume less alcohol some people
shifting away from alcohol to
cannabis um so those are a couple of
examples that the Liquor Commission
suggested as to seen some Trends as to
why their revenue is slightly
decreasing the other one is Lottery
Revenue which all goes into the
education trust fund that's ahead of
plan by $30
million and as I noted at the start your
education trust fund is below plan by
$24 million so if your lottery Revenue
wasn't doing so well the education trust
fund would be um not as not as healthy
as it is so I just wanted to highlight
those couple of
taxes um just to make sure it's not just
the Dr Revenue but there's other Revenue
sources that you need to be considering
as you um think about the impact on the
state budget going forward for the rest
of the 2425 bayum but also as you start
to think about building a new budget in
6 and
27 on page four you have the other two
types of funds that this committee is
responsible for estimating which is the
highway fund and the fishing game
fund both of those are
um excuse me the highway fund is
slightly under plan and the fishing game
fund is trending a little bit above
plan we'll see how that fishing game um
continues to Trend because it's now you
know fishing season and how many more
licenses they might be selling and
things like that but again those are
other two funds that this committee
should also be keeping an eye on As you
move forward through the next fiscal
year there was a question um raised
earlier about you know this is only half
the equation you know who keeps an eye
on the on the entire process and it's
our office we look at all the
expenditures and we look to see what's
happening with those we look at the
revenues and to see what's happening
with that and we try to keep an eye on
what was anticipated to happen and as to
and then apply what changes are being
made throughout the course of the year
um to give us a new point in time um
status so I'll hand this out after but
it's a simple one-page document that our
office updates every month at the end of
fiscal year 25 you expected to close the
general fund with a balance of 3.2
million and it was anticipated the
education trust fund was going to close
with a balance of 23 $ 32.3
million when the um annual comprehensive
financial report came out the actual
fund balance to the education trust fund
was $32.5 Million higher so we had a
bounce of
$264.83 million below for the education
trust fund as well as there was 40.8
million of appropriation variance so
basically when the um education trust
fund excuse me when the adequacy
payments for the education trust fund
were
calculated as well as the efas as well
as any other money that is um
appropriated out of the education trust
fund it was found that the budget was
$40 million short there's open
appropriation language so that the
commissioner can draw down the funds
necessary for that so that was a $40
million
variance so we project at the end of 25
at the end of the bium your education
trust fund will only have a balance of
197.4
million with the general fund I said you
had a starting balance of
3.2 through Revenue your plan is 68.8
million
ahead we anticipated a lapse at the end
of the um this year of $76 million right
now the agencies are forecasting um it's
going to be about 40
42 is so we're about $34 million short
of the lapse at this point in time we
know we're going to get more money but
we're not sure if we're going to get the
full
76 there's also been a number of
Appropriations that are statutorily
allowed um 24 almost $25 million of
these Appropriations these
Appropriations are things like workers
comp unemployment the death penal death
penalty uh excuse me death benefit for
individuals who die in the line of
service police officers um EMTs people
like that um as well as Appropriations
that are allowed to be drawn statutorily
through fiscal those are limited those
are things like litigation in the
Department of Justice engine and defense
through the judicial Council medical and
um Dental through the Department of
Corrections are the three big ones
there's a few smaller ones but there's a
very much a limited amount that can be
drawn through fiscal but again these
appropriate ation are not budgeted so
it's $25 million of unbudgeted
Appropriations so
far and to date uh the legislature has
passed $200,000 of Appropriations
through legislative specials this year
which sounds good so far until you hear
that right now between the house and the
Senate you have $138 million of General
funds in Appropriations and the various
bills that you have out there you have
another 82.9 9 million of Education
trust fund Appropriations contained in
bills that are still active between the
house and the
Senate so again we we worry about those
types of things in our office because
you may look like you got a big balance
this year you start passing bills that
have an impact not only in 25 but
they'll have an impact in your next
budget so I think to get to your
question represent ORS it we do take a
look at that um we do share this
information with leadership um both in
the uh majority and minority parties and
uh and and it's up to the legislative
body to make those
decisions if uh for some reason your
revenues were at a tank the executive
office um would have would be charged
with trying to manage the budget that
they have before them and they would
need to make some hard decisions if if
that were to happen so I don't want to
keep you all afternoon but I just wanted
to throw a few little tidbits at you and
the last thing I'll leave you with is
just understand that um you're talking
about revenues and potential changes
this does nothing to change the revenues
that are part of the plan those are
passed as part of the law the budget
Bill law so unless you amend that the
revenue plan you see for 25 will be
based on the revenues that were passed
in the operating budget and the
adjustments in the Surplus statement but
it is good information for you to know
the trends that are occurring right
now thank you
uh representative
Southworth uh thank you you covered part
of my question just looking at the
numbers um when I look into
2026 I see a loss of 150 to 200 million
with the elimination of the indd tax so
somehow that's going to have to be made
up either by um cutting the finance
budget um or really increasing some
others so I see that as a dilemma we
also have some giant bills coming um
depending what happens legally so I
guess to me and I don't need a long
answer it seems like 2026 is going to be
a very creative year for your
department uh we're not super excited
about 26 and 27 I I don't think you're
going to see the same revenues you've
seen in the last couple of budget
Cycles um there's going to be harder
decisions being made you're absolutely
correct
um there's been bills passed there's
been Appropriations provided to agencies
to to enhance and further develop
programs within certain agencies to
sustain that they're M there's going to
need to be some give and take um so the
governor will have the first crack at
building a budget the new governor um
and then it'll come to the legislature
and a lot of decisions will have to be
made but you're you're absolutely
correct reps Southworth it's it's going
to be
difficult representative
duet thank you and thank you for taking
my question Chris you want into uh some
forecasting as to legislation that's
still basically in front of us did you
look at the opportunities in legislation
to capture new Revenue I'm I'm talking
to a specific piece and what effect that
may have or any others so if if a piece
of legislation has a revenue impact we
would note that in our fiscal notes so
on every bill that has an FN or Bill
that's been amended that has a fiscal
impact we will do a fiscal note for and
in that we will note if there's um you
know the revenue estimate because we do
work with the agencies that are the
expert in those areas to get an an
essence or estimate of what it might be
in terms of the change that that's being
proposed in that legislation so we do we
do try to take that impact what I
mentioned earlier were just
Appropriations nothing talking about um
Revenue side because it's just a lot and
an not for us we were pretty surprised
right it's it's an off-budget year and
there was a lot of legisl specials with
Appropriations in it more than you
typically or that I've
experienced uh yes I'll move this way
Senator Lang I'm sorry because I missed
you said there was 197 million projected
for the education trust fund in Surplus
did you give a number for the general
fund and if so I just missed it what
your what it looks like going forward
now 112. six thank you and I may not
have said it I may have missed that but
I'll give the she all these expenditures
and
I'm sorry what was the question again so
my question was what is the projected
general fund Surplus okay um and it was
112 million minus any expenditures we
might do is the legislature that might
eat into
that representative le le thank you Mr
chair I have two questions um the first
is do you have that written out the the
numbers that we that you just shared
with us this is it and the second
question is the tobacco settlement money
is that stop at some point or do we know
when it ends and is it like a steady
decline so how's that I thought it
wasn't forever I I don't think it stops
but the amount will change every year
and is that based on their profits how
it's based on a number of different
things and I'm not even going to try to
pretend I can do you know give you an
explanation but the Department of
Justice has a person who's assigned to
track that and monitoring you know the
sales and what's going on in other
states and what things might be
impacting the tobacco sales here as well
as in other places and then they there's
also some legalities that are being
settled through the courts and and
negotiations so those sometimes have an
impact we did well we got just under the
40 million this year last few years
we've exceeded planed but there's been
years it's come in under um perf and doj
just does the best they can but they
know it's really not till April do they
know the exact number that ansers my
question and all that um just to so you
know the up to 40 million goes directly
into the education trust fund any amount
over 40 million goes to the general
fund representative
elberger thank you Mr
chair do you have numbers on the amount
that we've been spending on the
efas um we can get that I think the
appropriation this year was $24 million
I think is what they um was the cost of
what they put out this year that that
was um that was what was appropriated
but we know what the the amount
appropriated was 30 million there was an
amount a piece and House Bill 2 that
reduced that by $10
million but there's an open
appropriation language so can you get us
yep thank you
yep representative fellows thank you so
um you were telling us um some like an
example you told us that in education
trust fund there were um not
expenditures have exceeded what was in
the budget by 40 something uh million
correct and so when you those things
that you told us and about fiscal
expending approving 25 million are those
in here so on if you look at that same
line that you see the 40 million in
education you see the
24.9 that's that's the amount that would
goone has gone through fiscal or the
governor has drawn down money for it's
not all fiscal and I just want to make
sure you they're both in they're it's in
it's in here okay yep the 40.8 that's
again EFA and that and um the other
piece was the free and reduced amounts
um when the adequacy was done they
updated the numbers and it increased the
appropriation need okay
thanks but again I just want to remind
people the fiscal committee has a very
limited ability to appropriate funds um
there's sometimes confusion that fiscal
has the ability um to appropriate money
you know if if you had a program that's
falling short you want them to give them
more money they just can't do that they
have to be statutorily allowed and
that's pretty limited what fiscal
committee does do though is accept a lot
of federal funds so if an agency got a
grant or is awarded federal funds or
other funds being transferred from an
agency for a grant purpose they come
through fiscal and they can budget that
question yes Senator so again just I
want to talk about that $4.8 million uh
expenditure that's in there that was
unprojected uh out of the budget so
again that also would include we
adjusted the educ education uh formula
to deal with increases in free and
reduce and increase in extraordinary
need Aid based on property values and
that the change in a student that moves
all of a sudden you may have the same
number of students but you had a
thousand more that are now under free
and reduc
going to create an expit and that
thousand more may also then adjust that
equalized valuation per pupil for free
and reduced um as well and give grants
more grants to those communities so
again it it encompasses a lot of
expenditures not just uh we passed a
bill to give it to fund some new program
right the education funding
uh we were using data the best data at
the time when you were projecting your
budget shortly after the passage of the
budget doe got revised data going into
the fall um and then applied that to the
next adequacy um for
24 and that's where the differences were
found mainly and then there was a little
bit related to the EFA efas but um yeah
so most of it was just chewing up the
adequacy and that's why they have an
open
appropriation ability question any more
qu yes represent ORS thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question so you
know efas was brought up I read recently
that efas have saved to Public Schools
13.1 million can you either confirm or
give us a number or does that something
you look at we we haven't looked at that
we haven't so I I can't comment on that
per se okay we can just tell you how
much was spent out of the E the
education trust fund but I can't tell
you what was saved or changed as a
result of the local
expenses represent fellows so I'm I'm a
little bit confused about this because
it says um FY
2025 but
these so the first lines is that the one
you're pointing to that says FY 2025
well at the top and the bottom but these
are these are things that have happened
in FY 24 so this document the one-page
document is the banial information so
we're saying for the 24 25 budget this
is where we think you're going to land
next June based on activity we've seen
through fiscal 24 so far so you were GNA
take look at the first line so C can I
just follow for example if you look at
the variance that that's in the
education trust fund yep is that
40.8 is just what's happened in fiscal
year 24 so we assume fiscal 25 is going
to be right on plan because we don't
know right
now and they're not anticipating the
same change in 25 as you see here for
the education trust
fund so with the extra um four 40
million expended this year yep you
wouldn't there that's not expected to be
40 million next year is the budget
amount for next year more than 40
million the education the adequacy
grants over a billion
dollars I'm assuming that that um a lot
of that EX has to do with the the
education Freedom accounts no no it it's
it had to do with an adjustment the free
and
reduced
so this is you're getting into the
adequacy formula and there's a hold
harmless in the adequacy formula so as
you start to get more money in your
Grant you may get less in the hold
harmless so that may offset some of that
but I'm not I would prefer that you go
offline and we can talk with um somebody
in our office about that any more
questions for Mr
Shay seeing none thank you very
much one last thing you should have
seen a paper copy of the annual
comprehensive financial report and the
um Bond statement so it's I delivered
them to the office they may be in your
drawers or Karen may have them um and
and there was a question earlier about
the different it's the exact answer but
I think repon PL or repon Malloy was
asking about um you know could you
separate the types of businesses in the
state so on one of the pages it does
break out by percentage you know your
manufacturing versus non-manufacturing
and it gives you a sense of um durable
good non- durable then you and
non-manufacturing is it construction
wholesale retail service Industries
governance Finance transportation and it
gives you percentages and then after
that it gives you the um largest 20
Employers in the state so so there's
good information in this document as
well as the act for when you're thinking
about those types of things that at
least get your thinking thank
you okay that does it for today's
business any questions representative
Aly yes we also got on state revenues
add to Surplus uh from uh Phil slon who
has had to leave already on he was um
for a long time an
auditor in the state and um he's been um
learning to talk to us as versus to the
numbers and I think it's worth taking a
look at it even though he's only looking
at what happened in April at this
point thanks okay
yes just as the conversation I
understand before I got here you guys
did talk about the credit carry forward
and the percentage relative to the
credit carry I'm going to be repurposing
over in house over in Senate ways it
means House Bill 1525 she already taken
care of that through Senate Bill uh 472
so that's an un it's a bill that would I
would normally just itl I'm going to do
a non-gain amendment to that and and
notice it and I'm going to look at
pushing off the next ch the next two
changes by I think four years and I'm
willing to have a conversation with you
guys I think what is a good idea but as
you heard from probably Dr 50% of all
the refunds that were issued were a
direct result of the 500% forced refund
um and given what's going on with
revenues I'm a little nervous about the
idea of again forcing another change uh
that will generate NE because all of
those people will get a refund plus any
other new people um will get another
refund and so um I I'm open to anybody
who wants to reach out and talk to me
about how long my my idea was I was
going to push to 250 off by four years
and then push the other one off by four
years to give us two bienniums to see
what's going on with revenues and then
let it take effect or not um but I'm
going to do a non during amendment to
1525 and repurpose that bill um for the
function of dealing with this push off
of the mandatory refunds and that that
push off is 400% right no so right now
we're at we just went to the 00% the
next step down is to 250 no I know that
but you're the change you're going to
make is going to go to 400% no the
change I was going to make was just
strictly to put the effective date of
the next step down out four years right
so we don't step down to 250 for an
additional two budget Cycles so it's
going to stay at 500 then for it'll stay
at 500 where it is for now and then push
it off to push off the 250
implementation four years and then push
off the 100% implementation another four
years so it gives us a few bienniums to
make sure that revenues are where we
need to be before we we do this
mandatory like I said the the the
um we heard at least in the revenue
report I saw was about 50% of all the
refunds were issued because of the 500%
yeah force and so if we drop that down
to 200 we expect that everybody who is
just came underneath 500% is now going
to have to drop down again to 200% and
that's going to create a significant
impact in our revenue forecast so my
plan is to push that off a little bit
still keep it on on to happen but let's
give us a couple BMS before we force
that secondary mandatory set of refunds
sounds good yeah representative elme
yeah
um that
puts what you also missed on our
quizzing of uh of uh Lindsay about this
and uh they're feeling fairly confident
that the major hit
has happened at this point I'm not so
confident about that but I'd rather see
pushing off two years so that it should
give us enough time to see whether she's
right why don't you two get together
have a conversation what you think the
ways of Means Committee wants on the
house side and I'd rather again I'm
hoping that when I present the bill
will'll come over with a concurrence so
we can be done um rather than have to go
through another committee conference so
if you guys get together majority
minority and decide where you think that
should be I I don't I anticipate like
Lindsay that next year's revenue is
going to be fairly flat um and because
of that I'm nervous about forcing
another kick in of these of these um
mandatory uh refunds so I I think we
need a little bit of time to see what's
going to happen the year after that so
anyway you guys get together talk to me
I'm gon I'm just drafting the amendment
hopefully I'm going to get it in
tomorrow the next day but I can amend it
again on the in the committee if you
guys come up with something different
yeah I had misspoken earlier on because
I thought we were going to 400% and then
keeping it at
400% no I'm just going to push off the
250 and the 100% reductions a coupled by
enms out to give us time to see what the
revenue impacts are going to be okay
just uh I'd like to say that uh pushing
it out makes sense to me I think
um maybe two B what did you say two
budget Cycles yeah four years two budget
yeah that may be a little much but um
that's what we can talk about but it I
just wanted to say that I I think it
makes sense given the
commissioner's uh remarks it seems that
uh maybe the best available estimates
which clearly are dras is that uh it's
not going to be as severe a problem as
we might have feared but I'm glad you're
doing it again remember anything we do
is only good for two years right can all
be undone that's another truth yeah
well Tim I'm glad you were here today I
think you wasted all those years on
fishing game you should have been one
Ways and Means I was for
years I was all right I think we're all
set thank you
everyone e